Last night's state of the union address was
the epitome of the reality show, state of
[inaudible],
the union address, and it was kept by Nancy
Pelosi literally ripping up Trump's speech
inches behind Trump's head as he was mouthing.
Thank you. Thank you to people in the audience
in completely cartoonish fashion. So we'll
end with Nancy Pelosi ripping up the speech,
but that's not where I want to start. So we
were live streaming on a YouTube Twitch and
Facebook during the state of the union address.
And at the start of the speech I was fact-checking,
I was taking notes, I was trying to in real
time correct the lies and distortions of Donald
Trump. And about five minutes in I realized
there was no point in doing this. There's
no point in doing this in the traditional
sense of the fact checking here is pointless
number one because it's just constant lies
and distortions and deception. Number two,
because what would be the point today of going
point by point, lie by lie given what the
reality is right now, very different than
what it was in times past in the United States.
Either you are in one of three camps, either
you're on the side that knows Trump is lying
and you'd already don't plan to vote for him.
You're on the side that knows Trump is lying
or suspects that he is, but you don't care
because you've convinced yourself, well, all
politicians lie and you're going to vote for
him anyway, or you're on the side that doesn't
believe that he is lying. Whether or not you're
going to vote for him, fact-checking isn't
going to convince you. So the point by point
fact check is irrelevant in a sense, and I
don't mean it's irrelevant because truth doesn't
matter. I mean it's irrelevant because you
either don't need it or it's not going to
affect you. Just as a couple of examples,
there was constant deception. I'll give you
one. Trump bragged about how tons of people
got off of food stamps under his administration.
Take a look
under the last administration, more than 10
million people were added to the food stamp
roles. Under my administration, 7 million
Americans have come off food stamps and 10
million people have been lifted off of welfare.
Now, of course Trump cut food stamps so it's
not really an accomplishment to say fewer
people are now on food stamps. You just cut
the program and Kip kicked people off of food
stamps. It's like me saying, great news. I
was able to get 10 people off of life support
today. Isn't that great? Well, did they die
when you took them off of life support? Did
you cut off life support? They needed it or
are they now breathing on their own by itself
saying there are fewer people on food stamps
is not an accomplishment. One other example,
Trump talked about the number of people now
working in the United States is more than
ever before. The Republicans love this and
then when it's a democratic president they
love saying the number of people not working
today is higher than ever before. The population
of the United States continues to grow with
a steady proportion of people working and
not working at almost any point in time.
You can say we currently have more people
not working than ever before and it would
be true. And you can also at the same time
say we currently have more people not working
than ever before and it would also be true.
It's meaningless absent anymore context. So
those are some examples, but our time today
is not well spent fact-checking, a 78 minutes
minute speech that was riddled with lies and
deception. So I want to talk about the big
picture from last night because that's really
what I think matters. The summary, the big
picture is that this was a reality show met
to appeal to the lowest common denominator
using props and ponds and reality show stunts
the guests in the room who Trump referenced.
We're, you know, up in the mezzanine. We're
for the most part guests who had nothing to
do with Trump policy at all.
They were merely ponds and props. And I know
every time we, you know, every time we make
a commentary like this, some people say, David,
you're insulting those people. You're saying
they're stupid and they're being used as ponds
and props. It's not that simple. If you're
invited to the state of the union as the president's
guests. Most people go and you know to some
degree you're upon or a prop, but the degree
to which this was the case yesterday was sickening
example. There was a woman in the mezzanine
whose husband died in combat sometime ago.
It's horrible. It's tragic, but it was wholly
irrelevant to any Trump administration policy,
any Trump accomplishment or lack thereof.
It was just a a woman whose husband tragically
died in combat sometime ago. There was a woman
in the mezzanine whose daughter was born very
premature and she was thankfully saved by
technology that Donald Trump had nothing to
do with.
It's incredibly, it's an incredible story.
We're so glad that medical technology is advancing
so that more and more babies born premature
are going on to live healthy lives. It's great.
Has nothing to do with Trump. The that mom,
by the way, with the premature daughter also
went crazy cheering when Trump talked about
banning late term abortions, which of course
are incredibly rare, done in unusual cases
where they truly are necessary. And again,
that woman was a prop of cheering against
abortion and then the real, I mean just literal
reality show stuff. A woman whose husband
was deployed to Afghanistan was there in the
chamber with her kids and in literal reality,
show fashion is sort of, but wait, there's
more. Let's see what's behind door number
three sort of moment Trump says, and your
husband is not really in Afghanistan. He's
here. Come on down.
What a surprise. Creating reality television
in real time. And then, and we're going to
talk about this more. Yes, extremist right-wing
radio host. Rush Limbaugh, recently diagnosed
with advanced lung cancer, as we talked about
on yesterday's bonus show was there as an
invited guest of Donald Trump's and surprise
rush. You have just won the presidential medal
of freedom and Melania Trump puts the metal
on rush. We're going to detail that more in
a little bit. So then at the end, capping
the reality show state of the union. Yes,
Nancy Pelosi participated in the reality show.
She ripped up her copy of Trump's speech right
behind his head. Check it out. And hilariously,
you'll hear George Stephanopoulos here in
this clip talking about Trump's background
in reality TV as Nancy Pelosi rips up the
speech.
[inaudible] the applause right there. He came
out of reality television and he displayed
that talent tonight, 78 minute extravaganza
and touch and emotions both high and low.
So there were mixed reactions to Nancy Pelosi
ripping up the speech. Some people loved it
as a sign of resistance. Others said that
this is childish. It's really a mix. I mean,
visually it was very funny and I tweeted about
it and it fits very much with the whole reality
show vibe of what we saw yesterday without
real action and leadership from Nancy Pelosi.
It's merely a funny visual without any meat
or substance behind it. And then the saddest
part of course, of all of this is there will
be people, uh, to whom this speech really
appealed. They saw a soldier's wife and a
kid saved by medical technology that Trump
had nothing to do with. And they end up feeling
good about Trump because it is designed to
be emotionally manipulative in exactly the
way that it worked on some people. And they'll
say, I feel really good about voting for Donald
Trump now in November.
That is really hard to fight, but we're going
to devote more time to that a little bit later.
Let's talk now about the rush Limbaugh thing,